so learning to use many of the tools as
we all do uh so welcome everyone uh it's
a pleasure
uh to open the boot camp and open the
area theory program at the simon
institute thanks for the simon's
institute for supporting this
as peter said there is
a huge interest in our theory we are
very positively
pleasantly surprised about this uh
thanks
uh for everyone for the interest um
so before jumping into uh
talking about a boot camp uh i just
wanted to mention that
the whole program is going to run for
the whole semester
uh until december and in addition to the
boot camp we're going to have
uh three workshops uh and uh people can
register online
uh at the website and we're gonna have
uh dedicated discord
uh discussion uh
channels as well uh which are dedicated
to these
individual workshops the workshops are
deep reinforcement learning online
reinforcement learning and passion
simulation
in this order and for the participants
i'd like to have a town hall meeting on
the 8th of september that's next week on
on tuesday at 9 00 am
to get really the program of the ground
and and do being brainstorming about
how to structure the program for
ourselves so with that
uh let me uh go to
the boot camp
introduction um so um
this is the high level plan uh for the
week
um so on monday
uh you're gonna hear from uh mangry
and me about just basics of
mvps and planning and
in the afternoon we're gonna hear from
anka
so every day is going to be tutorials
and then a bonus talk
a little bit later in the afternoon
everything's recorded
it's going to be available on youtube so
we have to
stretch across the globe but time zones
uh it's gonna be difficult but i hope
that
uh we can include everyone i see that
someone asked the question yes uh
how do i see what the question was
that is feedback and two voices one
on top of the other uh not
not for me not exactly okay
all right okay good
all right so that's one day and and on
tuesday uh
we're gonna continue uh with online
reinforcement learning and batching
first math learning stefan's going to
give a talk in the afternoon
on wednesday uh
we will hear um
about reinforcement learning from
statistics uh perspective and ashley is
going to give the talk in the afternoon
thursday the contra perspective and
andrea
is going to give a talk on friday uh
operations research and
russ uh is going to give a talk
so that's the plan um we want to
uh keep this as much as possible
interactive
so please at any time if you have
questions
uh ask here
either in the chat i guess you can raise
your hand
or something like that and
also i asked the organizers to monitor
the discord server
uh so that if you have questions you can
ask those
ask ask the questions there and then
someone probably going to raise their
hand here and
ask me the questions uh so with that i'd
like to
start with the first part of the boot
camp
which is mdps and planning
so
all right let's get started
so um the structure
of uh so i'm going to talk uh
about really basic stuff for about 30
minutes
uh just introducing mostly definitions
uh i'm just talking about definitions
and
and some some really basic results
and then mangdy is going to come in uh
for 30 minutes then we're gonna take a
break
uh and then maybe comes back after the
break
and then i will wrap up the morning
so at the very first let me
let me see how i use this
at the very beginning i'd like to talk
about
definitions uh and totally reward mvps
uh and then talk a little bit about the
sufficiency of stationary policies what
they are
and and and in what way they are
sufficient uh
for mvps and then a little out look at
pump dps
so let's uh kick off uh not even talking
about mdps but
talking just about uh markov control
processes um so micro
control process is like an mvp except
that
we took away one piece of
the mdp which is uh which is the rewards
so what we're left with uh are are the
states
um and they're collected in a set uh i'm
going to denote that set by capital s
so that's this set and uh we have
a collection of actions then those are
collected in this
a and the collection of uh
transitions these are collected into
this capital letter p so what are these
transitions these are trans
markov transitions so this is a
collection
of uh
probability distributions uh one for
each
uh state action pair
so lowercase s and lowercase a
are going to denote individual states
and actions
and uh to minimize clutter i'm very
often just going to write sna without a
comma and without parenthesis and
whatnot
so that means the same thing i just
don't want to introduce a lot of clutter
uh but apparent so so what happens here
is that for
each uh state action pair there is a
distribution
so psa is a distribution over next
states
so uh if i need to talk about a
distribution
over some set i'm going to use this
notation of
m one of uh and then in the argument
the set itself so this is the collection
of all distributions so this uh for
every state action pad we just have a
distribution
um and uh so the um the idea here
is that uh you start a process uh
at some uh state s zero
and then somehow you determine some
action a zero
so that's that's coming from uh you the
controller
uh the agent or whatnot and together
uh this state and the action uh result
into a next state that's s1
and so this s1 is a distributed
uh according to this uh distribution
s not uh and a naught okay
and then uh you come in and then you
choose another action and when you're
choosing this action you could use
uh uh basically uh
the first state s naught and a naught
and s one the whole history that that's
what we're gonna call the history
and this process uh continues this way
so um
in each and every arrow here uh we're
using
this uh markov transition kernel
so let me make this a little bit more
orderly
all right so this this results in this
next state and then my new action is
chosen instance of force
um so uh we can also
illustrate this using a little diagram
so on the diagram so time is discrete
so t goes from zero and then it's
incremented
by increments of one so you started
st at time t and uh you have a little
controller
that can have some memory and it can
also randomize
uh somewhat to denote randomization but
uh so this controller uh we also call
uh the the maps that it implements the
policy
is going to compute eventually based on
the information available to
it uh and action a t and this a t
is is fed into uh this system
so that and the system uh has its state
and
and it's making transitions the
stochastic transitions
it makes a transition to to the next
state which is
st plus one and and this is chosen from
this
uh pst 18 probability distribution
and so then this state comes out and is
fed back to uh to
uh to the controller and and this way a
loop is closed
and uh this results uh
in a sequence of state action pairs
an infinitely long sequence of state
action pairs
all right you see that there are some
questions i don't know
m1 is just a function of the
state space uh it's it's because
um okay
so the first question why m1 is just a
function of the state space
it's because these distributions are
over
uh states i hope that uh
now that i i drew the diagram and and we
have this process u
it's clear that the action component is
you know coming from a policy
and the state uh the next state
component is coming from
the system that that is being controlled
and so this is called markup control
process because
uh the next state distribution only
depends on
uh the previous state and the action so
the control part is the action
and uh the markovic part is that you can
discard all previous states uh
and the next distribution is going to
stay the same
um another question would you mind
quickly go over the notation of p again
um so p of s of a so for each
uh action pair s of a that is that is a
distribution or over the states uh
so you can also think about that you
have the state space
here and then uh you are at some state
and then you choose some action uh that
comes from the
different state uh different space and
that
uh induces a distribution over the state
space so you end up in this this cloud
like with some probability you're
reaching each and every step
uh and then the process continues this
way i hope that this is
clear um
so um in the mark of control process uh
so uh this m
we are given this s and a and p
and uh and we're just setting up things
uh we're not talking about uh anything
uh beyond that uh all right
okay so given um
uh the state space an action space and
these transition kernels these are
called markov kernels as well and
and if you have big spaces then they
have to have you know necessary measure
with these properties
uh but that's uh let's just disregard it
uh
for now uh for the sake of uh time
um so if you're given this
then you can fix a given um state
and then you can choose a policy and
then
uh given the markov transition kernel
this results
in a distribution over the
space of all trajectories
so so this is uh
the trajectory space
so these uh trajectories are these
infinitely
uh long sequences of uh alternating
state action pairs
and i hope that it's it's clear how this
distribution is constructed um
the uh the uh
the distribution on each and every
component is
uh you know like an s naught uh
uh that's a direct distribution to that
s and
uh a naught is is determined based on
on the policy its distribution and s1 is
determined based on you know like it
sits here
uh based on a transition color and so
forth
you take uh all of these uh
probabilities if you're in a discrete
setting and then you multiply everything
together
and that gives you the probability of a
trajectory
and if you are in bigger spaces then you
can do this
uh extend this idea to these bigger
spaces in
appropriate manner and so here the
important thing is that i'm going to use
this notation of p
of s and pi which is a distribution
over uh these infinitely long sequences
of state action pairs these trajectories
these are distribution over trajectories
and
um if you have a probability
distribution then
of course you can introduce an
expectation operator and and i'm going
to use
a similar notation for that so this is
going to be the underlying expectation
operator
and if we have an initial state
distribution mu
so here mu is a distribution over
our states then a similar construct
uh leads to uh distributions over
uh trajectories uh and
uh similarly uh we can introduce this
expectation operator e of mu of
i
all right
i think i did answer
pretty much all the questions
i would say
i don't understand someone said yes now
but
all right okay
um so we have constructed this uh
probability distribution
given an initial distribution initial
state a policy
and a markov kernel uh over the space of
trajectories
so what are we going to do about it uh
so we need a control objective for the
control objective we're going to
use the words uh so we pick a reward
function
r so
this is uh this is your your reward
function right
sorry
okay so it maps state action pairs
uh to real numbers uh so this is my
notation for your numbers
and um so if you have a trajectory
uh i'm also going to denote trajectories
by just
uh age so if you have this
uh directory
then you can assign
a return to the directory
which is just the sum
of rewards along the trajectory
is an optional discounting
so these are called this is also called
the immediate reward function
because you receive these when you are
making a transition
and here this gamma is this
this con factor and many times we choose
it
smaller than one and if the
words are bounded uh then this would
ensure
that this function over the trajectories
is very defined so
so capital r is the return function
and and this this sum is just called the
return
okay so once we have the return
we can define
the value of a policy
so the value of a policy is if if you
start a policy at
a particular state of s is denoted by
v of pi of s and it is defined
as the expected value
of the return
okay so so recall that uh
so this p is the probability measure
over the trajectories and so this is
this is basically uh if you have you
know
uh uncountable many trajectories then
you would need to use an integral
notation so let's let's go that way
but if you have um
finitely many uh state action pairs
then you can just enumerate
all the uh trajectories there is going
to be countable many of them and then
this integral becomes
just this sum
all right
there is some bead that is annoying
but i don't know about that
sorry about that um
if i knew what is the source of that b
i won't get rid of it for sure um
anyways um so um
so this is the value function uh so i'm
sorry
so this is the value of the policy pi in
state
s and if you collect all these values
then
v of pi can be viewed as
a function that maps as state to
area values this is going to be called
the value function
of a policy pi
and there are many variations um
so the variations uh would include
uh you know there is no discounting
there is discounting
okay maybe uh the horizon is going to be
finite
so maybe
8 is finite or maybe it is infinite
and sense of force
sometimes uh you restrict the set of
actions
that are available at the given state
and you have this admissible
set of actions and
sometimes you consider other criteria
like the average cost
uh i'm not going to talk about this uh
it would take
too much time to to talk about this as
well
all right
so um the control objective
it is shown here
in the bottom so let's let's focus on
this
so the control objective is to find a
policy pi
such that for every single state
this policy maximizes
uh the values that can be achieved
if you're free to choose a policy even
depending on pi
so this this value here this is defined
as the
optimal value function
or the optimal value of state s to be
precise
and if you collect again all these
values together then you get
v star and b star is just this map that
maps
uh states to two rears and this is
called the optimal value function
and um solving uh
an mdp means that you are able to
find a policy pie such that
this policy achieves the best possible
value at
every single state
so in planning we are asking the
question of like
how can we do this so planning asks
the question given an mdp
what is a computational procedure that
gives us
an optimal policy
so how do we get a procedure
and so when we say that we are given an
mdp i'm not too clear about what i mean
about that
so in the next part mandy is going to
talk about
uh the case when we had a finite
mdp so in this case the number of states
number of actions is finite and you can
animate
uh you know like the state transition
matrices uh they they just become a big
table
and you can enumerate everything the
value functions become
vectors and
you can in this case
talk about that you can find or not
an optima policy and how long does it
take to find such an optimal policy
given the information that is fed to you
so the information could come in this
form that you're giving these big tables
and and it's it's a good uh thought
exercise just to think about how we
would do this computation
but of course that's not really
practical uh
many times uh we have much bigger
number of states and also large action
spaces
so that this enumeration is not
practical in the last part i'm going to
talk about
uh what we're going to do in those
kitties before that
i just briefly wanted to mention one
thing
about uh effective horizons and
discounting so if you have a discount
factor and you're shooting for an
epsilon accurate
evaluation of a policy then what you can
do is that you can
cut this infinite sum
that was um so in this case uh
the horizon was infinite
so you can cut this infinite sum
um at some um
finite horizon this age gamma
and and you can set the age gamma to be
uh like log one over epsilon one minus
gamma divided by one minus gamma
and so if the reward function
i'm going to assume this uh
takes values in the zero one interval
then this ensures uh that you don't
lose much by cutting the trajectory
short
and so here this h comma and
sometimes it just like one over one
minus the gum
ignoring the log is called the effective
horizon so this is just based on you
know like
uh taking the maximum values here
which are one and
the maximum differences that you can get
and summing the infinite series uh
from uh h uh gamma plus one
sorry from
and and so this is this is just going to
be gamma to the power of
h gamma plus 1
times 1 over 1 minus gamma and so if
this is
uh smaller than equal to epsilon which
is ensured
uh by this choice a little calculation
shows that
uh then you can be sure that you're not
missing much
in terms of the rewards and so if you're
interested in
absolutely accurate evaluation of your
podcast
then the lesson is that you don't
actually have to cancel infinitely
long horizons but you can
cut the horizons short and this is used
a lot
in a lot of different arguments that's
why i
put this up first so now
the next topic is uh okay so we set out
to
uh to find an optimal policy or maybe
just an absolute optima so i i didn't
say
much about that but the absolute
optimality would be to find some policy
pi such that we have pi is bigger than
equal to v
star minus epsilon uh
and and let me write just one so this is
a vector notation
uh it means that for every state uh the
value of the policy would be above
the optimal value minus epsilon so that
would be the absolute optimality
criterion
and so the question is
in what form should we
search for like this and
uh in a nutshell the answer is that uh
we should
uh it is sufficient to just uh
look at stationary policies so what are
what are these stationary policies
so a policy could have memory
could use past information previous
states and previous actions
when it comes up as a distribution over
the next states if it uses randomization
or it could be
deterministics it may or may not use
memory
and may or may not use randomization
so let's first stick with randomizing
policies
if the policy uses memory but only step
counter so it remembers like how many
steps uh we are in the process and
depending on that
it chooses a distribution
uh that is based on this counter and the
last state
and and the distribution is your
reactions so then we're talking about
markov policies
and a policy which is a markov policy
which uh doesn't use the counter so it
doesn't have any memory
so it could also be called memoryless
policy maybe that's a better name
no worries or pure
state feedback so these are all uh
different names that people use in
different parts of the literature
then you arrive at stationary policies
so the claim here is that
from the perspective of finding an
optimal policy
it is going to be sufficient to just
focus on stationary policies
why is that so the reason that holds is
because of this little proposition
so this proposition says that um
if you take any uh distribution over the
states and you take any
policy arbitrary policy that can use
memory and randomization and whatnot
then you can always find a stationary
policy such that the value
of the stationary policy when the policy
started from this initial distribution
is the same as the value of uh
this arbitrary other policy when it
started from that distribution so here
uh the value is defined
my pen is misbehaving a little bit
so the value of a policy pi is defined
as usual the expected value
of
the return
and uh of course you can
exchange so let's let's assume for
simplicity that rewards are bonded
um that that's always very helpful then
you can exchange
the
infinite sum and the expectation
uh by the dominated convergence theorem
and for simplicity let's assume
that you have um
countable many states and actions then
then you can
replace this expectation uh by this sum
now you take the probability that the
state at time
st is s
and the action at time
t is a and
just multiply this is the individual
rewards and take the
sum over all possible direction pairs
and um so we can call this
uh sorry uh just just do one more step
so then we can swap uh the sum
over the state action pairs
and the infinite sum
and we can just collect the terms and we
see
that this expression arises
which uh i'm going to denote by
mu of mu of pi
at s a this is the definition of
nu of mu of pi of s a
and uh this is called the discounted
occupancy measure let me just put this
here
so for each state action pair uh we're
assigning this number which is the
sum discounted sum of the probabilities
of the process visiting that given state
action pareto given time step
and so this is called a discounted
occupancy measure
okay um so
towards this proposition so let's recap
so we wanted
we want to show that uh for any
arbitrary policy it suffices to consider
just a stationary policy to reproduce
the policies value from a
given initial state distribution so for
this we started to rewrite the
uh the value of this policy pi
and we find that this um
value can be written basically as the
inner product
uh between the discounted occupancy
measure or just the occupancy measure
and the immediate reward function
so you could just write this in a short
form
like this if you introduce an inner
product notation
you can view this just as a big vector
and this is a big vector
so this is just in my product between
these two guys
and uh so based on this it's quite clear
that a proposition would hold true we
would see that it holds true
if it holds that if i choose an
arbitrary policy pi
and i take its discounted occupancy
measure
then i can reproduce this discounted
occupancy measure
with the help i can produce the same
uh occupancy measure as this
is the help of a stationary policy
so the proposition will be shown to be
true
if it holds that
for any uh oh i had a lot of space here
um so for any uh
policy pi so it's enough
to show that for all pi
that exists at pi prime
for all mu and pi raises to pi prime
such that the new of mu
of pi is equal to the mean
of u of pi prime
so how how are we going to do this
uh it's a simple procedure um
we are going to explicitly construct uh
the spy prime uh and the idea
is just to marginalize so take this uh
so fix this arbitrary mu and fix the
arbitrary pi so this gives us
this occupancy measure mu of pi
which gives you you know this this
number for every state action pair
and we need to produce a stationary
policy a stationary policy
the distribution over uh
actions given a state so
a simple way of of doing this is to
uh to marginalize and a good way so so
this is uh
how it's going to work uh so just
we we just take this uh discounted
occupancy measure
and we divide
by the marginal
so mu of mu of mu of pi
of s is going to be the sum over
all the actions
of the same thing
and
if this is non-zero and uh and and we
assign an
arbitrary uh distribution uh
if this happens to be
zero so this is
fine not is it's just an arbitrary
distribution over
actions uh it doesn't matter
what distribution you choose uh so
i really i um yeah
i don't know whether i should go through
uh
why this is enough maybe i go through
why this is not just just very quickly
so let um
let's define this uh markov kernel
uh pi of s of pi
prime of s prime as
uh you know this uh
given a state s uh policy pi prime
uh first chooses an action a uh
with some probability and then we are
making a random transition
according to uh the transition dynamics
that we have
and uh so note that this this can be
uh written as the sum
of uh
because of the definition of pi prime so
just plugging in the definition of
pi prime
yeah just just this one okay
and now the argument goes as follows
so if you take
this marginal distribution
then this is just uh
by definition uh
this discounted sum of uh
visitation probabilities
of this particular state and you can
break the sum into two parts and you
will see this argument many many times
so this uh probability distribution of
course for t equals zero
it's mu of s because that's your initial
state distribution
and for all the other errors uh you can
you can just pull out
a gamma and you get gamma of t
plus one of uh p
of
and um so now
we're going to use the markov property
so just sum over s
prime and a
slow after that probability
sorry this is just because i pulled out
the gamma
already
[Music]
so i want to bring in
the
occupancy measure that's why i'm doing
this uh
so i write this probability i expanded
based on
uh what the previous direction pair
could have been before we arrived here
and then that introduces the mark of
kernel
um so we're going from s prime
uh using action a
to state as
and now you can see that
this is just a new of pi
at s
prime and a
and now you can start to see that
uh we have the same expression as as
i don't know letter is uh clear but i'm
pointing
we have the the same expression as here
except that s
is here s prime and that s prime is s so
for
swap s and s prime uh so
using this um
we get that this is mu s
plus gamma
times sum of s prime of
a of
pi prime
sorry
i need to bring in a name of
mu of pi s prime because i need to
divide
and multiply and
then um i have the sum of reactions
uh i can replace that uh
just uh this this
prime t s
prime
let's put
and now this is nothing but
the transition color that we introduced
before
this is uh p of pi prime
[Music]
s prime s
and with a vector notation uh
what we derived is that mu of
mu of pi is equal to mu
plus gamma times
mu of mu of pi
p of pi prime
i know the argument is that uh
this equation has a unique solution
in terms of uh knew of me of pi
and uh by repeating the same argument
you can find that
the unique solution of this equation
is actually mu of mu of pi a
prime so it follows that mu of mu of
pi is equal to mu of mu of prime
prime so uniqueness gives me this
and and apply this this uh this horse
same reason in this pi set to pi prime
right uh so so that shows that this
shows that
uh this construction
uh does everything uh that we wanted
so the corollary to this um
i'm using a little bit too much time
to curl it to this is that
there exists
a pie which is a stationary policy
which is optimal so why is that
it's because uh we showed that
stationary policies are sufficient to
uh
to reproduce the values for
any given initial state of any policy
and so
first you can construct the policy uh
i mean okay so for really the existing
not absent optimality
you need to have some additional um
nice structure assumptions but for
example if the state action
space is finite okay so let's let's be
uh specific uh state extreme space is
finite
uh then you can first find a policy
which is optimal
right so the optimality definition was
that
the policy needs to achieve the maximum
value at
every state action pair if you start
with an
initial status so that's that's a new
that
is a direct address uh then you just
have to
maximize this this in a product and so
you can find a policy
uh that really achieves that value
and that's because uh the space of
occupancy measures
uh it also falls from this derivation
is is a nice compact convex
set uh this you can uh
see from somewhere here
in the middle uh
like you start here and the occupancy
measure
satisfies this this equation here
so you can plug this in and cross out
this mass
and so that's just a linear constraint
on the occupancy measure
and uh and you can show that if you have
them
uh some other constant small negativity
and some harmonization constraints then
uh every element every um
measure every uh function of state
action pairs
that satisfies this linear constant
occupancy measure
and and it's a nice convex combat set
and then you can find a policy that
maximizes the value
for a given state and
if since the policies are not restricted
you can also stitch together policies
and find a single policy
that looks at the initial state and say
that oh like if if the initial state is
this then you just use this policy which
is optimal for that initial state
you stitch the policies together because
policies can remember what was the very
first state
and so this way you arrive at the policy
which is um
which uses memory it remembers the very
first day
and is optimal and uh once you have that
you can reproduce the value of this
policy
by uh stationary policy and and which
stationary policy well this stationary
policy
doesn't depend on um what
what the initial status solution is
going to be it happens to be
true uh so it follows that
there exists a stationary policy which
is optimal
uh i guess uh maybe maybe it's going to
talk a little bit more
from a different angle about this and
it also follows that there exists a
policy uh which is
deterministic which is optimal
all right uh my time's really up
uh so i just wanted to say a few words
about
powerful observable mdps uh so
um
the previous figure showed that the
controller or policy receives the state
and and very often it is the case that
the state which is the summary of all
the past information
is not available for measurement and
a more general way of thinking about
control systems
is not to assume that the state can be
observed
so still maybe there is a state uh that
is being updated
but instead of having a mark of kernel
that
gives you next state and then you
observe the state you have a mark of
kernel here q
which gives you a pair of states and
actions
and states and observations so this is
next state
obviously and and this is an observation
that is going to be
fed to the controller so in this case
the contract can only use the
observation
and uh in a way this is the real deal
this is how
most of the time control systems need to
interact with
uh with their environments
and the question is uh can you extend
any of the
things that were previously said to this
case
uh this happens to be innervate true
as if you start with with an initial
state distribution
new knot which is known
given to you then
uh the marginal distribution of the
state given a history at some time step
t uh let's denote it by mu of t
uh satisfies a recursive update so mu of
t
can be seen uh to be
computable as a function of the previous
distribution uh the last action and the
last observation and and for this you
just need to use
base rule basically and
it happens that you can also think about
mu of t
as being randomly sampled from some
underlying
transition kernel so this way uh we're
lifting
uh the problem of computing
optimal policies uh from uh
policies that depend on states to
policies that depend on distributions
so an optimal policy in pundit peace
would
you know keep track of uh this ronald
measure this
belief state or belief distribution over
the state space
and i would use that as a summary
and then you can try to generalize
results the constructions and so forth
all right um so i think that with that
uh i'm done uh let me see better
well i used a lot of time so should just
wrap up
oh what happens uh
when the reward is not bounded well you
need all kind of regularity conditions
or you could have costs even
in order to be able to define uh values
in some policies may not have values the
same problems happen when
you don't use discounting uh and
uh in this case is people assume what
kind of regulatory conditions so that
to make sure that uh even uh you know
the notion of optimal policies
is well-defined um
all right mandy are you around
hello yes okay sorry uh
so we ran a little bit over time sorry
about that
uh that's all right i i'll try to be
very high level
okay let me see if it is
onto um my
screen i yeah i can't share my screen if
you're sharing yours
yours okay okay how do i
share
okay does it work i think so
yes okay um so next
so we want to talk about the very basic
methods and complexity results
for planning in march of decision
processes
and like as travis has mentioned like
reinforcement learning
is a very broad problem and there are
many
problems that are extremely hard like
partial observable markov decision
process
and also for continuous problems with
unbounded space
usually the problems become harder and
there's a lot of like nuances
so to talk about complexities again so
we want to
focus on the simplest finite state
finite action markov design process and
assuming everything is bounded
so this is a notation we are going to
use we have a finite
set of states a finite set of actions
at each state and action we have a
reward which is a scalar
and we have a collection of state
action to state transition probabilities
so all of those are input
to the algorithm and based on those
we're trying to
solve the optimization problem and find
the optimal policy that maximizes
the cumulative discounted sum of rewards
okay so this is just a statement of the
problem we have already simplified it
to uh the most so no unboundedness no
partial of the
uvp everything finite okay so usually we
call this tabular markov decision
process because we don't really have
much
structural information or additional
prior knowledge here
just a discrete computational problem
okay so what are the basic methods
so so first whenever we talk about
solving markov decision
problems we usually always write down
the optimatic condition
which is known as the belmont equation
or the optimal belmont equation
so the optimal value function which we
call the v-star maybe
your slide is stuck at the title slide
ah sorry i think that happened to me
a lot i have to yeah stop
the presentation mode does it work now
hello yes i see the yeah
about a bellman equation yes okay yeah
so i was talking about the basic
notations
and now the bellman equation okay
so um we want to compute
the optimal value function and in the
discrete case the optimal value function
is just a vector
and the dimension of the vector v star
is
s the number of states okay
so there are three major classes of
deterministic algorithms
but they turn out to be the foundation
to many learning algorithms
so we'll just go over them one by one
but very briefly
so the first one actually before we go
over them
yeah we need to uh
introduce a notation called the bellman
operator
so the bellman operator comes from
the belmont equation here
so the bellman outer is going to be the
operator that
maps some value function here to the
left hand side
so it's defined in this way so
we can apply the bellman operator t to
any value function
and it will work in a way as if it is
doing one step look ahead
basically by treating this v as the
value function the next step
and try to compute what's a better
value function at the current stage
okay and know that this is definitely a
non-linear
operator and we also need notation for
the bellman operator we called t
pi for a fixed policy
so if we fix the policy then the spelma
operator is really just a linear
operator we simply try to evaluate
the expectation of future value
by using the probability for choosing
actions based on the policy and also by
using this
v function as the next step value
function
okay so
belmont the bellman operator has a few
very elegant and fundamental properties
that are basically the key to a lot of
analysis
so the first property is the contraction
property
uh wait a minute my apology i think i
miss the discount factor
gamma here and here we need to have
these count factors
okay so once we are talking about
discounted
markup design process with gamma between
zero and one so
it's pretty easy to prove that the
bellman operator is strictly contracted
with respect to the l infinity norm and
the modulus of contraction
is bounded by gamma the discount factor
okay so we don't have time to prove it
now but this is really it's really an
easy
exercise another important property is
that
the bellman operator is monotone
meaning that if we start with two
different functions
v1 and v2 and say v1 is point wisely
greater than or equal to v2 and after we
apply
the bellman opera t to either to both v1
and v2
this relation still holds so monotony
multiplicity in value function is going
to be preserved after a partial
environment operator
okay so based on the two properties we
can see that belmont operators are very
nicely behaved
and also it's easy to show that the
optimal value function v star
is the unique fixed point of the bellman
operator
and the value function for fixed policy
is the unique fixed point for the
bellman operator
t pi okay so those are very basic
properties
but we do know that with especially this
contraction property
harvey relies on the fact that we have a
discount factor
so in some way like the process the
process always returns
to some dummy state with probability
one minus gamma so we can think about in
the in in
by using a reduction so somehow the
process always return
to a fixed point but that's why we have
contraction
but if we don't have a discount factor
if we talk about undiscounted infinite
higher than dt
then the property becomes tricky and one
can show that
this property no longer holds for our
infinity norm but holds for a variant of
l1 norm
and there's another story a longer star
right there which i i won't be able to
tell today
okay so the first very basic
algorithm is called value equation
so the algorithm is extremely simple
it basically says that we start with any
v0 any vector of dimension s
and then we just apply the bellman
operator t
to that vector over and over
so this is called value iteration but
this is really just another way of
freezing dynamic programming we're just
doing backward induction
okay and it's uh
about the value iteration a very basic
result is the value equation
converges exponentially in l infinity
norm
and this is a simple
corollary from the contraction property
of the bellman operator so basically as
as long as we are iterating the bellman
operator
our value functions are going to
converge very fast
to the optimal value
and similarly we can always derive
the policy from the value function and
the policy will converge to the optimal
policy okay
um so if we try to do some
final calculation to calculate all the
arithmetic operations needed
in applying each value equation so we
can show that
the runtime complexity for value
equation is the following
so it's of the order s square to a
so s squared times a is really the size
of the transition
matrix so it's really the size of the
input
so this time complexity is linear to the
input size
and also if our discount factor is very
close to one then the convergence rate
will be slowed down okay
so a slightly more complicated algorithm
is known as the policy equation
so instead of iterating belmont operator
in the value space
we try to do that in a policy space okay
so again we start with an arbitrary
policy pi zero
but we try to improve it incrementally
so to improve our policy we've always
try to evaluate it first
meaning that we want to first compute
the value function
corresponding to that policy
which is equivalent to
solving a linear system of equations but
we write it abstractly like this
t pi k times a t uh i would say p pi v
pi
equals v pi we are trying to solve this
equation
okay so once we solve this equation we
obtain the value of the policy pi k
we try to improve it by basically by
again doing
one step value equation or one step look
ahead
so we're trying to find this new policy
pi k
plus one such that by applying
this policy for one step we're actually
doing
the optimal bellman operator we're
actually applying
it's actually equivalent to applying the
optimal balance operator
okay and in a way that's similar to the
proof of value equation but slightly
more complicated
one can show that policy equation also
converges linearly
and the modulus of contraction is again
determined by the discount factor
and for undiscounted problems there's
again a longer story which
we we don't tell today
so so so why do we care about power
situation
it looks like it's more complicated than
value equation right so what happens
is one the algorithm is iterating over
the space of policies
the space of policies is in some way a
smaller
space than the space of value functions
and there are some subtle difference for
example it's known that
power situation is strongly polynomial
but
value equation is actually not
but however if we just try to implement
product situation in a
straightforward way with just a regular
equation solver
we call that whenever we try to policy
evaluation we need a linear system
solver
so if we just use a naive
solver the complexity won't be too good
so we actually get quadratic complexity
with respect to the input size okay
so that's the second approach and the
third approach
is quite different from the first two
so again recall that we are trying to
solve the belmont equation
but now instead of trying to utilize
properties of this t operator
we may equivalently rewrite the belmont
equation
into a linear program
basically we're trying to say that hey
we're trying to find
this value function such that left-hand
side of the bellman equation is always
greater than or equal to
the right-hand side and then we try to
lower
the left-hand side so that's the
intuition
and this requires a little bit of proof
which is again a very nice exercise
okay so if we can write
the bellman equation into a linear
program is going to be a linear program
of dimension
s times a times s so it's going to be a
big
linear program so
what's interesting is we can look at
the dual of this linear program so this
is like
the linear program in the space of value
functions right
but if we try to write down a store we
are going to associate
the constraint with lagrangian
multipliers
and the dual program has a very
interesting
interpretation so the two variables we
call it
lambda okay
so it turns out that the optimal
dual variable in the linear program
corresponds to
the discounted augmented measure under
the optimal policy
so in some way lambda star tells us
about
some long-term stationary state action
distribution
when a good policy is chosen
and if we try to interpret the dual
lp we can see that
let's look at the constraint first this
is a linear constraint
and this constraint is equivalent
to requiring that this lambda
is the opposite measure corresponding
to some policy
okay so now we are searching in the
space
of occupancy measures that are possible
under this mdp and within all such
occupancy measures we try to find the
one
such that we maximize its inner product
with the reward so the inner product
between
an augmented measure and a reward is
exactly the value function
so basically this says that we are
searching
we are optimizing over the space of
attainable opposite measures directly
and that's the dual problem okay
so uh if we think about this problem
purely as
a linear program and we try to use the
best interior point method or the best
lp solvers
so there are a list of uh best known
results
for using lp solvers to solve for using
for using triple measures to solve this
problem and again we can see that
even this better result has super linear
dependence on the input dimension
okay and comparing to the one we have
here
this value equation this similar
algorithm actually has
linear dependence
so it might seem like lp methods
might not be the perfect algorithm for
solving this particular problem
so we can we can actually see why this
is true because
if we are treating this problem as an lp
we are not
utilizing the contraction and the
monotone properties of the bellman
operator
we are only using the fact that it's a
print lp
okay but
one thing interesting is if we look at
this particular dual linear programming
okay
we realize that we have a space
of state action organizing measures
right and if we are familiar with lp
then this space of lambda is a big
polyhedral
and we have many vertices on this
polyhedron
and it turns out that the vertices
of this lp constraint corresponds to
deterministic policies
okay and one can further
show that the policy tuition
the algorithm that improves policies
one by one so that algorithm is
equivalent
to a variant of block simplex method
applies to the dual problem so there are
very there are many interesting
correspondences there that are
fun to analyze
okay so last slide
so uh the best known upper bound to my
best knowledge
is this one so
this is a runtime complexity obtained by
using a variant of value equation
but with a lot of algorithmic hex and
randomization
to help accelerate to help accelerating
it
and as we can see this complexity is
near oh it's almost linear
in the input size so we have some
multiple factors by this
logarithm and there are some additional
factors but hopefully this is much
smaller than input size
so we will say this is almost a linear
time solver and it could be the best we
could expect
and as for lower boundary results so
there was
the seminal paper by papa dimitrio and
johnson ticklish
so they showed that solving i mean i'm
solving mbp is definitely a polynomial
time problem and it's p complete
but although mdp is simple and nice
but if we have partial of durability the
problem becomes really hard
so solving palm dp is p space hard it's
even harder than
np complete so it's just much much
harder if we have partial observability
so having states that give us the
markovian property is really a blessing
okay and also there was this uh
classical result that if we try to
computationally solve a continuous state
continuous
action mdp with smoothness
then the runtime is going to be like
this
so basically it's going to be
exponentially bad in terms of
dimension of the state vector n
and action vector m okay
so finally i just want to say that most
of the results
for discounted mdp extend pretty easily
to finite horizon mdp so as java
mentioned
so it's pretty straightforward to read
to how to construct a reduction for
example we can always approximate
a discounted mdp with a finite horizon
one by just choosing the horizon to be
long enough
to be like this order and the other way
is
um we can always approximate
a finite horizon mdp by
picking a good discount factor in a
discounted entity
so those results for titanium bt
and mdp um almost all hold
for finite hard mdp but if
we talk about undiscounted even horizon
then the problem becomes much harder and
it's not
within the scope today okay so i'm going
to stop here
and we're going to have a short break
and then we'll continue
in probably 20 30 minutes
right um so that is this gather town
link
uh it was uh
posting a chat somewhere and i think you
should just head there and then you can
continue having some conversation there
okay i'll be there see you soon
and then we come back at uh in 20
minutes
um okay so there is the link again
uh if you haven't used get your drone
you just click on this and then you are
a little avatar and then you can
go near people and then if you're near
to someone then you can talk to them
all right uh leave this open and
uh just
yeah can we also copy the uh
this link to this card maybe
yeah i put it in a couple places on
discord okay
yeah thank you
you